vanessa what's up i am going to be 37
this year
and i don't really have any friends and
i don't know how to
make friends oh that sucks doesn't it
it really does i hate that for you are
you new to town
tell me about not having any friends
well i
um i'm just i don't know i'm shy and i'm
awkward
and um hey me too i
am too hey listen i was walking into the
building today
and there was two people that i work
with they are awesome
they are awesome and instead of saying
hey what's up you know what i did
i went oh i made some weird like
noise and i just stopped in the parking
lot and i was like
i i just made that so weird
unnecessarily
i should have just said hey what's up
guys like a normal per
i remember in college my friend mitch
showed up and i ran over to
i still anyway i'm awkward and shy too
it's good to meet another one of you you
made my heart feel a little bit better
today all right so
you are i just made this all about me
sorry vanessa i just had
almost like had a confession this is not
a fish okay so
you are awkward and weird and how long
have you not had friends
the majority of my life okay tell me
tell me when you remember not having
friends
um it was in 1991
i was oh you know you remember the date
i do it was very traumatic um yeah
it's okay we moved from
my nice stable environment to a very
nice
not nice unstable environment um
we moved to a village
it was literally a village the
population was a hundred
and you know my my parents had recently
got divorced
my mom started dating somebody else and
they just kind of uprooted us
and shifted us away
um so everything in my life everything
in my life changed i had to start taking
a school bus
i had to go to a new school new teachers
no friends nothing
and um it sounds really silly but i was
the
only kid in the school that had red hair
hey vanessa vanessa listen
that's not silly at all kids are
evil to each other and every little kid
is walking around insecure
and so they lean on differences they
lean on the sore thumb sticking out they
lean on the new kid they lean on the
redhead kid they lean on the
the no-haired kid they lean on whatever
right
there is nothing weird about that and
you layer
that challenge right being the only
redhead kid
with being the tall girl or the short
girl or the pudgy girl you label that on
top
of parents divorce on top of hey
everything's good all of a sudden
everything's ripped out
man you've got a lifelong thing that a
recede that was planted at six that is
still
growing strong at 37 right yes
so listen do not please i'm not telling
you what to do you're a grown-up
i'm just asking you as a neighbor don't
minimize that that sucks and i hate that
okay that's hard so fast forward through
middle school and high school
sometimes the awkward kids pair off and
make friends with awkward kids that's
what i did i
had awkward friends that played music
together and awkward friends that
i i was a good athlete so we got to hang
out with you know the the cool kids and
but that awkward kids lived on my street
i mean i i was just felt like i was
surrounded by cool fun awesome
also awkward kids i think in retrospect
every kid in high school is awkward but
um
did you you sounds like you navigated
your way through middle school in high
school
just pretty much alone um
up until high school like i didn't
really have um any friends
until 10th grade um and then
a couple you know fellow weirdos kind of
took me under their wing
and that was awesome but after high
school
everybody just kind of scattered and
we all lost touch with each other and
um i actually grew up in
canada and then i married
an american and we moved you know
down to the states and so you know kind
of started fresh
started over didn't know anybody never
really fit in with anybody down here or
up there because i'm in florida now we
were in
indiana and then when we got divorced
i packed up and i was like tired of the
winter i'm tired of the cold
i'm going to florida hey vanessa why did
you
why why'd your marriage not work out
um there was a lot of reasons but the
the main reason was that my my
ex-husband
um convinced me to have an abortion
um that i didn't want to do he gave me
an ultimatum
know i choose the baby and the streets
or i
choose him and our home
[Music]
and you chose the baby and still ended
up out of that home
no um i didn't i i had the abortion
and um it was incredibly traumatizing
it was the worst experience in my life
i've ever been through
and i just really disconnected after
that because i got no support from him
whatsoever and things just deteriorated
after that
so what do you do for a living now i am
a pet stylist sweet
okay so you're in a job where people
are eccentric and they bring you their
eccentric
pets and tastes and loves and
all that so you just meet people on a
regular basis and you interact with
their pets on a regular basis right
i do um i actually just quit my job
about
two weeks ago to start my own business
okay um so i you know i have
a lot of people that i know um just
nobody that i'm really close to gotcha
so just in your retelling of this to me
do you hear
just the roller coaster of trauma that's
woven its way through your life
oh absolutely and what
what the gasoline the coal that keeps
that roller coaster
riding strong is shame
and worth an unworthiness yes
i'm a failure i screwed up and i'll
always screw up
yes and i failed myself i feel people
around me i'm awkward and you come up
with these narratives like
i'm awkward i'm a little bit weird but
the reality is
you don't like you is that fair that's
100 accurate
okay and so the longer you live in
worlds of secrecy
the longer you live in worlds of i suck
i am not worth liking then
people aren't going to race to
be in community with you right okay
and i don't think you don't have friends
because you're awkward because i'm
real awkward and i have some really
great friends
i'm really awkward and
here's the thing you are going to have
to
believe in yourself that you're worth
having friends
and then you're going to have to do the
hardest thing you're ever going to have
to do in your life
at this stage in your life moving
forward and that is to once again
risk and all
friendships all relationships are a risk
yeah i'm gonna put it out there and will
they show up
and if they do show up am i gonna screw
it up and you have a two-fold risk
are they gonna show up and are you going
to screw it up
right right most people have a hard
enough time with
with the first part of that risk
equation or they can even
come right and
i want you to know you're not the
dumbest thing you've ever done you're
not your parent's divorce
you're not your parents uprooting you
you're not your red hair as a child
you're not
the the deepest shame you carry around
you're not and
you've got to believe i'm worth being
friends with
i'm worth bri i'm going to bring things
of value to other people and the things
i'm going to bring are not utilitarian
they're not my cooking or my laughter
they're you
you are the benefit to other people
right
okay yeah and just it's
it's hard because it's super hard have
you dealt with these traumas
um no um actually um from
listening to to your podcast um i've
actually because i i was in
um after i moved down to florida i was
in an abusive
relationship with a narcissist and um i
started going to
talk therapy and um you know i got my
life a little bit back on track and then
got out of that relationship
and then my life totally exploded
and i ended up homeless and the past
four years i've just kind of been
trying to get back up on my feet and
now that i'm back up on my feet i am
back in counseling awesome so when you
project to the world
i have no value i'm a loser i'm the
worst thing i ever did
i'm not accountable to even to myself
there is a kind of person
who's attracted to that and that is
somebody who will use you
abuse you you will become an end to
their means
right right i'm sorry you'll become a
means to their end
and that's how those cycles continue and
then you find yourself in an abusive
relationship
and somebody hurts you and instead of
them getting their
um owning the weight of their evil
the shame cycle continues right because
that's what shame does it it
it beats up its owner right absolutely
so you're doing the right thing going to
counseling
tells you that you're worth spending the
money that you're worth the time
getting a job that you feel good about
where you have good talents
where you show up every day where you do
good
work where you help people with their
pets or their lives or their
their friends or whatever that's going
to help you
be a person of value and then this is
going to sound
weird and we have completely abandoned
this in our culture and so we literally
have to learn it
you're gonna have to learn some skills
uh on
friendship you're gonna have to practice
being a friend
and that sounds ridiculous because that
seems like the
easiest thing in the world to know how
to do right like
yeah because when your kids you just all
get together we had some people over the
other night and
i don't even know what they were doing i
just know my daughter comes running out
of the house in a frozen dress with a
bow and arrow
and my son i don't know what was
happening but they just created a game
out of nothing and there was all
different age ranges they were just
in it right right when you're 37 you
can't do that
right if you show up to a local pub
wearing a frozen dress and a bow and
arrow they're probably going to call
somebody right
probably and so you have to practice
skills
what does that mean here's a good
example i just made a weird
howling wolfy noise in a parking lot and
i had to stop
and say hey i just made that super
awkward i'm
i'm sorry and one of the guys knows me
well his name's brad he's awesome
he's like so lovely and he said hey man
just keep being you
and that was them saying we know you're
weird and we love you anyway
right there are those people
and you are going to make awkward jokes
you're going to
be talking to someone and someone's
going to say something that's going to
remind you of your childhood it's going
to remind you of the pregnancy
that you lost it's going to remind you
of an abusive ex and your heart's going
to take over it's going to start racing
you're going to have
you're going to be anxious anxious
anxious and you're going to get up and
walk out
and that's when you text them and you
say hey i'm sorry i walked out on you
i totally had some bad memories my bad i
will never do that again let's circle
back up next week
and that's what i mean by practicing how
do you sit there and with your counselor
i want you to tell your counselor hey
counselor
i want to practice relationship skills i
want to practice
being a good friend and your counselor
if they're worth
one quarter of what you're paying them
we'll be able to teach you some of those
things
and then you're going to be able to
project value to the world
because you're gonna have the skill set
to be a good friend
and again this is not utilitarian this
is not oh she's the one we call when we
need it nope
this is just i'm vanessa i'm worth being
friends with
and by the way vanessa you've had a a
traumatic history let's make no doubt
about it right you know that i know that
all of our listeners know that but i
don't want you to feel like
you're by yourself because i know people
who are
deathly lonely in a crowded space with a
family and a couple of kids
i know people who are lonely who just
lost a loved one and don't even know
they don't even know what day it is
right because they're grieving so hard
there are millions and millions of
people who are
lonely lonely lonely and i want
everyone to start risking
friendship start going out there and
saying hey
i'm lonely and i know you're lonely
let's go get a drink let's go get some
pizza that's going to give us
gas and make us not sleep well let's go
do so let's go kick a soccer ball let's
do a thing let's go for a walk whatever
i have a good friend named cassie i
learned so much about hospitality from
her you know why
she just kept having potlucks at her
house her and her husband gordon they're
incredible
just kept inviting people over and they
were awkward conversations there were
people that were like didn't get along
at work but suddenly showed up at her
house
and you know what she just kept doing it
and she was so lovely and we were always
greeted with a hug and we always had
good conversations and played games and
talked about literature and law and
weird stuff
and i thought oh my gosh this is what
friendship looks like
this is what showing up and showing up
and showing up and showing up
she just kept going first she just kept
going first she just kept going first
and my wife and i learned what
hospitality learned what friendship
looked like from her
and be curious not judgmental
right say yes be safe right you got a
trauma history be safe but say yes be
open for adventures
but vanessa at the at the at the very
bottom here you've got to know you're
not the worst things that have happened
to you
you're worth being loved you're worth
being well and you're worth being in a
relationship with other people
i'm proud of you because i know going to
counseling is hard
i'm proud of you for wanting to strike
out on your own but i want you to get a
job where you're making some real money
right and you got to go to work every
day you need some structure right now
and i want you to be
bold and direct with that counselor and
say i want to learn some skills on how
to connect with people
because what you need is relationships
and what's hurt you has been
relationships
so you've got some healing and some
learning to do in there i'm
so so grateful that you called vanessa i
i need you to know that you just helped
a lot of people
you helped a lot of people being
vulnerable and telling about your story